unbelievable video of train tracks in
los angeles littered with open packages
thieves are stealing and emptying
containers filled with consumer goods
everything from electronics to
medications to even covet test kits the
union pacific railroad says it's trying
to protect its cargo by increasing
patrols flying surveillance drones and
working closely with the local police
but the company claims that local
prosecutors are not helping jonathan
vigliotti shows us how even the suspects
who were caught are not always stopped
it looks like something from the wild
west
only it's happening in bustling downtown
los angeles thieves are breaking into
the cargo of trains and stealing
thousands of dollars worth of
merchandise at a time
the debris field stretches on for as far
as you can see we're talking about
easily tens of thousands of destroyed
packages with addresses ranging from
washington state all the way to
pennsylvania we've seen a number of
covetes discarded but the packages with
electronics and home goods were left
empty this is just unheard of on friday
union pacific spokeswoman lupe valdez
said from october 2020 to 2021 there was
an increase of more than 350 percent in
thefts
in a letter to the district attorney's
office in december the company blamed
the no cash bail policy in part for the
frequency of the thefts the railroad
company reported a loss of at least 5
million dollars at the beginning of
december
that amount is expected to go up once
union pacific factors in year-end
holiday shipping all of us shop online
these days and this is something that we
are also paying the price for
in a statement the district attorney's
office said they make their charging
decisions based on evidence or lack of
and they hope to address the issue with
the railroad company in the following
weeks for cbs morning's jonathan
vigliotti los angeles
[Applause]
you know guys you look at that it looks
like a very bad accident as opposed to
something that was deliberately done i
know i saw washer dryers i saw that too
the train tracks yeah